that is true noble nuclear reactor
number four it melted down on April 26
1986 so what happened was so much heat
was generated inside that reactor that
it basically blew the top off spreading
radioactive isotopes throughout this
whole surrounding area and over into
Europe and that is why we can still
detect the contamination here today and
they covered it in that sarcophagus
which is kind of crumbling as it ages
and so they're actually building a
brand-new containment facility over here
which when it's finished will be slid
over on top of the old containment on
top of the old sarcophagus the town of
Pripyat was built just a few kilometers
away from the reactor mostly to has the
families of the people who worked there
and now it is completely abandoned so
now you can find all of these high-rise
Soviet apartments completely empty and
crumbling and the forest is basically
reclaiming this whole town when the
residents of Pripyat were told to
evacuate they were told that they would
only be away for two weeks so they left
most of their belongings exactly where
they were and they never came back
so their lives are on display here
I'm inside an old kindergarten and it's
incredibly peaceful you know you look
around and it looks like a disaster is
hit here but mainly what this shows is
thirty years of weathering no
maintenance so things just fall apart
[Music]
the most insidious thing about radiation
is how invisible it is you can't feel it
you can't smell it or see it this could
be pristine wilderness but it's not it's
a contaminated deserted wasteland this
is what a real post-apocalyptic world
looks like abandoned buildings overgrown
streets everything crumbling rust things
breaking near the reactor there's an
area called the red forest because after
the accident so much radioactive
material was dumped in that area that
all the trees died and their leaves
turned red just like they do in autumn
I'm standing on the stage I feel could
be a theater something about this place
that just I can picture the scene I can
picture it here a packed house all the
great Russian productions that were
staged here and you look it around at
all the old lights and the layers upon
layers of walkways they would have used
this is a pretty amazing location this
is my favorite place so far nothing
radioactive it's just an amazing look
and the past of this place
[Music]
everything is so recognizable and so
familiar and yet it's it's being
destroyed it's crumbling and nature is
reclaiming this whole area this is what
the world would look like if man
disappeared one day all of a sudden this
is what it would look like thirty years
later
I filmed this video while shooting a
documentary for TV all about how uranium
has shaped the modern world for details
about when and where that'll be
broadcast check out the description and
thank you to everyone for writing in to
request that this be broadcast in your
area we are working as hard as we can to
make that happen
and order to make it available online
because I know most of you watch most of
your content online just like I do so we
will try to make that happen you know I
really want to thank you for supporting
me because I think without your support
and the support of my longtime sponsor
audible.com I don't think I would have
been selected as the host for this
documentary and this is the part where I
tell you about audible the leading
provider of audiobooks in all areas of
literature it's got hundreds of
thousands of titles and fiction
nonfiction and periodicals this week I
wanted to recommend to you a fiction
book which is the Martian by Andy weir
if you thought that that was an alien
landscape what you just saw
imagine what would really happen if
there was a disaster on another world it
is an awesome book and will be made into
a movie later this year so you probably
want to read it or listen to it before
that happens and you can download this
book for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium or you can pick
any other book of your choosing for a
one-month free trial so I really want to
thank audible for supporting me and I
want to thank you so much for watching